on a invité une de ses spécialistes
Nadia Gosselin vous êtes directrice
scientifique du Centre d'études avancé
en médecine du sommeil on peut pas être
plus spécialiste que vous bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous confirmez c'est pas
la meilleure chose à faire c'est pas la
meilleure chose à faire en fait il y a
aucune bonne raison de faire le
changement d'heure il y en a plus de
bonnes raisons donc on le fait par
tradition on le fait aussi parce qu'on
suit nos voisins du sud des Américains
qui poursuivent ce changement d'heure là
mais au niveau de l'économie culturelle
physiologique il y a pas de bonnes
raisons de faire le changement d'heure
au départ 1918 à peu près c'était après
la guerre pour les usines on ça allait
ajouter une heure de productivité en fin
de journée c'est ça l'origine n'est-ce
pas exactement bon et là vous êtes on
s'aperçoit que une heure de plus l'été
dans le fond oui on en profite un peu
mais il y a plus d'effets négatifs que
positif mais en fait la Société
canadienne de sommeil s'est positionné
pour dire qu'il y a pas d'avantage à
faire le changement d'heure bien qu'on
apprécie les longues soir mais en fait
il y a beaucoup d'effets négatifs donc
on sait que dans les jours qui suivent
le changement d'heure au printemps il y
a plus de crises de coeur il y a plus
d'accent de la route et il y a plus
d'accidents de travail donc ça a des
conséquences au niveau de la population
le fait de changer d'heure parce qu'on
manque une heure de sommeil dans une
population qui est déjà en carence de
sommeil donc ça n'aide pas et si les
Américains demain matin décidaient
d'arrêter de faire ça d'ailleurs il y a
une commission la bouche de génie qui se
penche là dessus on arrêterait le au
même moment là probablement il y a pas
de lobby au Canada qui milite pour le
changement d'heure en fait la Société
canadienne de sommeil dit que ce serait
mieux de garder leur normal donc leur
divers donc si on arrête de faire le
changement d'heure il va falloir choisir
est-ce qu'on garde l'heure d'été donc
leur avancée ou bien on passe à l'heure
normale pour toute l'année donc leur
divers c'est là qui est débord en fait
et qu'est-ce que vous en pensez en fait
on sait que la lumière du matin c'est la
lumière la plus importante la lumière du
soleil parce qu'elle contient beaucoup
de lumière bleue et cette lumière bleue
là bien qu'on en parle parce qu'on dit
qu'on n'est pas elle est néfastes en
soirée et les bénéfique le matin il nous
faut de la lumière bleue pour
synchroniser notre horloge biologique
qui est situé dans notre cerveau et donc
avec leur normale on a accès à plus de
lumière le matin l'hiver et ça nous
permet donc d'arriver au travail et à
l'école en ayant reçu de la lumière du
jour avant d'entrer dans en classe au
travail dans à l'intérieur et là ce
qu'on a fait hier c'est qu'on se prive
d'une heure le matin de de
d'ensoleillement à la fin du début du
soleil il y a beaucoup trop tôt le
soleil se lève à 4h35 le matin l'été en
fait l'été il y a pas tant de problèmes
parce qu'on a beaucoup de lumière le
problème c'est l'hiver il faut choisir
est-ce qu'un auteur de lumière on l'a vu
le matin ou en fin de journée finalement
est-ce que la Société canadienne de
sommeil dit c'est plus important d'avoir
le soleil une heure le matin que de
l'avoir en fin d'après-midi donc on
garde l'heure normal pendant toute
l'année c'est la position de cette
société là quelques secondes êtes-vous
fatigué qu'on fasse ce débat chaque
année vous avez hâte qu'on arrête de
faire ce serait une bonne chose de
régler ce débat là c'est certain ça nous
donne l'occasion de parler de
l'importance du sommeil et son n'en
parle pas assez donc voilà très bien
Madame Gosselin merci beaucoup de nous
avoir parlé puis on rappelle entre 7 et
9h idéalement de sommeil n'est-ce pas de
façon régulière oui bon très bien merci